well today is a lucky day we're
welcoming the whole uh you know Indian
Olympic team welcome company
well you just made the draw and uh just
a second before I asked uh harik a
question if she has any superstitions
and there was this discussion in the
studio so do you have any that you can
share with us
well yeah sometimes I do use the same
pen if I win some games or the same
jacket or shirt it does happen often uh
if I lose something even though if it's
a new shirt I I just don't wear it for
the game
I think most of the chess players have
this type of issues but okay generally
speaking those just like you know just
emotional attachments but apart from
that
we just love to play chess
of course
um well I've already forgot what I want
to test yes
you are our defending Champion uh well
uh three years have passed since the
last edition how does it feel to come
back to some place yeah it's really nice
to be back in America but you know we
have been more used to playing Europe so
after coming here there was a lot of jet
lag and tiredness I think
my game has also affected a lot and
uh probably from the if I look at my
games in the first and second rounds I'm
a bit disappointed with that I really
hope to come back
okay and um Elizabeth shared with us for
example that it's very important for her
to swim uh other players France what are
you doing at four in the morning
push-ups you know I just go for a walk
okay just for some fresh air okay thank
you so much well and hope that you come
back stronger thank you
and